-I'm so happy to see you.
Welcome back, and thank you
for being Goatleg Greg.
I appreciate it.
-You know, I've
got goatskin trousers.
You get this with the rest of
the goat.
-You really are a method actor.
-Yeah, I am.
-I was going to ask you
because I was reading
up about you,
and I think you've been
acting for over 60 years.
-62 years.
-Is that unbelievable?
Congratulations.
-Since I was 15.
-15.
And you started working
behind the scenes?
-Yeah, I started -- I mean,
I started -- Well, I used to
take the money to the bank,
which in Dundee was
a very dodgy thing to do
to get a 15-year-old boy
to take the money to the bank,
because I could have scarpered.
-Yeah, exactly.
-With the takings.
And so they gave me
a lot of trust
and it was a great --
it was a great start.
-And then I read that
you were a stage manager.
-Oh, I was the worst stage
manager ever. Absolutely.
-I thought you'd be great.
-No, no, I was terrible.
I would get bored,
I'd be --
The actors would be acting away,
and I'd be on the book,
you know, and the wings
in my prompt corner.
And I'd be on the book
and I'd be on page 15,
and they'd be on page 21,
you know?
-You've got to be on your stuff.
-Exactly.
So I'm there like this,
and there's a tap
on the shoulder,
and I turn round
and it's the actress,
and she says, "Telephone."
I said, "For me?"
She said, "No, on stage."
[ Laughter ]
-You had to bring the prop.
Yeah, that's your job.
Go bring the tele--
-Ring the phone. Ring the phone.
-Exactly.
You've obviously starred
in countless productions
of things.
I'm sure not everything
has gone well with everything.
Is there anything that sticks
in your mind of a moment
of something where you go,
"That was a nightmare"?
-Yeah, yeah, I actually --
when I was 44,
I played King Lear
at the British National Theatre,
and I had a moment where I had
this very voluminous gown
and I had to take my crown off,
which was a metal crown,
and throw it in the wings
out of anger.
I threw it, but it caught
in my costume
and it went straight
into the front row,
and this woman turned
to her boyfriend
and said, "Oh, darling,
you're covered in red."
And she'd cut her head and the
blood was all over his shirt.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Nobody else could see it
because it was in the front row.
So I'm thinking, "Oh, my God,
what am I going to do?
What am I going to do?"
And so I ran.
I got off stage
and I ran quickly
to where the lady
was being attended to.
And she was -- It was
a very minor cut, thank God.
And we gave her a free year
and her and her boyfriend.
But the follow-up was like 20 --
I think 20-odd years later
I was doing a play in Edinburgh
and I got this message saying,
"I'm bringing a new wife
to the show tonight.
Please do not throw anything
because..."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you got to be careful.
You got to -- Self-defense.
-Absolutely.
-Last time you were here,
we showed a clip
where you were teaching
a 2-year-old Shakespeare.
-Yeah.
-And I thought
that was fantastic.
Do you think that anyone
is capable of being an actor?
-Everybody is an actor.
They're all --
Everybody is an actor.
I mean,
that's what I've realized.
You know,
whenever you do something,
you act, you know, I mean,
even you, you go to the gym,
you probably act
that you might be healthy.
[ Laughter ]
-I do.
-That's a performance.
-Thank you.
-Everybody acts.
It's a thing, you know?
-Yeah. So we're all actors.
-We're all actors.
We're all actors.
So I just merely translate
everything that people do.
That's my job.
-Let's talk about this.
"007: Road to a Million" thing.
First of all, you know,
I'm a fan of you,
but I am a giant fan
of reality shows.
I love reality TV.
I really -- Everything,
you name it,
I love it --
"Below Deck," "Housewives,"
whatever you want me to watch,
I'm in.
"Survivor" is my jam.
And then you get James Bond,
007, and you get the real people
behind the Bond films.
-Right.
-Barbara Broccoli.
Well, you see,
I thought it was called
"007: A Road to a Million."
I thought it was
the new James Bond film.
[ Laughter ]
So I said, "Oh,
finally they're getting me
in a James Bond movie."
And I thought --
-So you said yes without even --
-I said yes.
I thought, yes, of course.
-"Don't even show me
the script."
-Show me the script.
There was no script.
-No, it's a reality show.
-There was no James Bond movie.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
-So I was doing
this reality show, but --
-I think you would be
great in James Bond.
-Well, I know, I mean,
she's -- she's --
[ Laughter ]
I know.
I mean, I thought --
for years I thought,
"Yeah, I'd love to be
a James Bond villain.
It'd be really interesting."
And I thought,
"This is my moment."
-Yeah.
-But it wasn't.
-It wasn't, no.
But it is fantastic though.
Did you enjoy doing it?
-Yeah, it was fun.
It was great fun.
I mean, you know,
I love bossing people around.
So that's what I did, you know.
I bossed all these people around
and they --
And they went through
so amazing.
I mean, it's a really good show.
I urge you to watch it because
what's interesting is
there's an Indian couple in it
and they found a new
relationship in
their marriage because suddenly
they were able to trust
one another after so many years.
It was very touching to see.
So it was a really,
really interesting show.
-It's so exciting and I love it.
And I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Brian Cox in "007: Road
to a Million." Take a look.
-You're now standing on Lascar,
one of Chile's most active
and fearsome volcanoes.
It last erupted less
than a year ago,
sending a column
of superheated gas and ash
four miles into the sky.
You'll find the question
at the top,
beside the crater, at 5,500
meters, and well into the zone
where altitude sickness
can be devastating.
You're going to need to be
especially vigilant
on your journey,
as I have decided that only one
of you could ascend the summit.
-It's like, "You. You go."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Brian Cox, everybody.
"007: Road to a Million"
premieres
this Friday on Prime Video.
We'll be right back
with Maren Morris, everybody.
Stick around.